l'enquète sur le gang qui a enlevé
torturé à mort le jeune ilan le réseau
sera apparemment plus important que
prévu et en dehors de celui qui se fait
appeler le chef des barbares d'autres
membres seraient en fuite le point avec
amaury guibert you didier robert à la
brigade criminelle de paris les gardes à
vue sans chaînes au moins une dizaine
mais leur nombre varie car les
enquêteurs ont la conviction que les
membres du gang de bagneux sont sans
doute plus nombreux que prévu
six personnes sont d'ailleurs activement
recherché en plus du chef présumé
youssouf fofana
audrey 24 ans est l'une des premières
mises en examen dans le dossier
cette étudiante qui voulait devenir
assistante sociale et la petite amie
d'un membre du gang
elle est soupçonnée d'avoir servi
d'appât lors d'au moins une tentative
d'enlèvement
mais devant les enquêteurs elle a
précisé avoir refusé de séduire ilan
halimi
tout ce que ça mais c'est que quelqu'un
été kidnappés en valeur de lâcher très
vite contre de l'argent
bon dans ce milieu là on donne pas senti
famille pour une affaire de
d'extorsion de fonds mais portait la
ville lors de la faire là elle n'a pas
hésité il seconde les enquêteurs
essayent maintenant de mieux comprendre
le fonctionnement du gang mais aussi ses
éventuels antécédents ainsi des
rapprochements seraient en cours avec la
campagne de raquette qui a visé des
médecins parisiens en mars 2005 il avait
accordé des arrêts de travail
complaisant avant d'être l'objet de
chantages une grenade avait même explosé
devant le cabinet de l'un d'entre eux
dans le 16e arrondissement de paris
en enlevant ilan halimi et en se lançant
dans le kidnapping crapuleux le gang
aurait donc franchi un palier en fin
d'après midi une marche en mémoire du
jeune homme a été organisée à paris
silencieuse au départ la manifestation a
tourné à l'appel à la vengeance
un peu plus tard notre équipe a été
agressé par plusieurs individus aux
visages masqués